We have a situation in Fargo.
A pilot of ours claims who
have gotten into a dogfight
with an alien craft.
The plane has the battle
scars to prove it.
[screaming]
I'll get down
there right away.
I need you to meet
with someone first.
Name's Dr. J. Allen Heinich.
Teaches astrophysics
at Ohio State.
You've done great work for us.
I think it's time we
got you a partner.
You want me to
investigate flying saucers?
I want you to help me prove
to the public the truth.
They don't exist.
Could I ask your opinion?
Which shade do you
think works best?
Neither.
It's just with your
hair color and features,
pinks won't works.
Something a bit bolder.
Susie.
Mimi.
What do you know
about men's ties?
Gentlemen, I'm told
you boys are here
to make this all make sense.
Keeps mumbling this
song "How High The Moon."
Won't tell us why.
This thing was moving fast.
It moves sideways.
The goddamn thing, it
was toying with me.
MAN: The flight
maneuvers he described
when that light was going at
him, best pilot on the planet
couldn't do it, sir.
How do you explain the damage
to the underside of his plane?
What type of UFO could do that?
- I'm sorry.
UF what?
Unidentified flying object.
This is a new science
we're creating here.
It needs its own terminology.
I think I can
actually identify what
it is for which [inaudible].
A weather balloon.
Our flight record records
show there was one
in the area that night as well.
Look at this.
Solid metal.
Fly too close and scrape
that, it'll leave a mark.
Mimi, I'm new in town.
Where are all the fun
spots in Columbus.
And if you say the roller
rink, I'm going to squeal.
I don't think I'm the
right person to ask.
Alan and I used to rumba
down at the rec center,
but he works so much, you know.
Just picked up another job.
Really?
Doing what?
He can't really talk about it.
You show me what a
weather balloon looks
like at 5,000 feet, and
I will agree with you
and write the report.
But until then, the
math says otherwise.
You want to play chicken
at 3G's just prove a point?
All right.
I'll take you on a ride.
Show you what those
numbers really mean.
Look out.
[engine zipping]
What's happening?
We're going down.
Brace yourself, Doc.
MAN: What the hell
were you doing
up there in the first place?
Testing a theory.
I don't need you
disproving a theory.
I need you to write
reports and close cases.
And if you can't, I'll
find someone else who can.
Where's the professor?
Do you mind if I ask
you a few questions?
What is it about that song?
This is how it communicated.
The song playing
through your headset
could easily have come from
a radio station nearby.
No.
No, no, no.
This came from my hometown.
I mean, I recognized
the familiar voice,
the DJ call sign.
This is KKJH, San Diego.
Logically, that's
not possible.
Logic can't begin to explain
what we're dealing with here.
MAN: I can get a flight
back to DC from here.
I'll fill out the
report by myself then.
I already filled it out.
I sent it off this morning
Well, what did it say?
Just what we proved.
That it was a weather balloon.
The tank's a little low.
Need to fill her up.
This encounter goes
deeper than we think.
At least, we may have another
candidate in our hands.
- What are you doing?
- It's OK.
[grunting]
You won't remember a
thing when it's all over.
[muffled radio voice]
There's something
you need to know.
The song [inaudible] heard
from San Diego, it's--
Hey.
He was telling the truth.
I just confirmed it
with the radio station.
MAN: Don't start with this.
It's not just the song.
I think there's
something more going on.
MAN: Connect it to
what just happened?
What do you mean, connect it?
[muffled voices]
You know what?
I'm-- I'm wrong.
I'm overthinking this.
The case is closed.
What are you not
telling me right now?
MAN: You're going
to rest easier now.
[music playing]